very good how are you good
so we know very little about how you
came to be in that bedroom we know very
little about how that this entire pg-13
thing came to be so can you tell me what
what was the lead up to being in that
bedroom who's there who's in charge who
was who was running the show man I don't
know I would love to find out I I got a
phone call from Ryan who I didn't know
who just called me on my phone or big we
heard perfect I said how did you get
this number
and he goes oh I want you to do this
movie and I said that sounds like a bad
idea why would you put mash up those two
movies that doesn't sound great at all
who would wanna go see that and then and
then I was on the set who was in charge
he see I mean I don't know how if you
know Ryan he just not personally he
seems to bark a lot of orders at people
it's fair so I don't know who was
technically in charge but he just seemed
to be you know just the honor and a lot
of people could you tell me I once you
got over that that that process that you
just described but what it felt like to
have that that Jersey back on what it
was there any sense memories that came
flooding back was there anything that
was you know when you smell something
brings you back to your childhood wasn't
anything like that
yeah it smelled great and the Jersey for
sure I think it was new but I was always
a big Walter Payton fan so that was that
was that was good to wear that Jersey
but yeah that was good hey fair because
we couldn't get any F words from you in
the movie I'd like to get some from you
now okay I'd like to play a few rounds
of a [ __ ] marry kill dad I don't know if
you're familiar with the game act pick a
person I want to do each one of those
things with alright I'm a married man
okay this is all good fun the apologies
to your wife for this all right we're
gonna start off with juggernaut cable
and Colossus I don't know
movies no juggernaut just based on the
names based on the names oh okay
well juggernaut cable or Colossus
well juggernaut seems like a real
sporting fellow so I would maybe
juggernaut cable Colossus cable uh I
don't know
I'm bad at this game I don't know those
people
I don't want to kill anybody okay keep
them all um
Colossus I don't know if something I
could protect me
so maybe that'd be good Mary and then
juggernaut look I don't want to you know
put the cart before the horse but very
very cool see where it leads
it sounds low yeah baby take in a movie
Matt Damon Brad Pitt and Celine Dion I
mean I'm you know I don't wanna I would
man I know it's tough it's tough it's
part of the job oh gosh well I'm Mary
Mary because I feel I could be married
if I marry one of them it'll be great at
first and then a few years and I'll just
be like what did I do this you're both
so busy are you again and then we're
gonna go to hate each other
oh that's marriage though that's
marriage not mine no but so I don't want
anyone to hate me I would like to I
think I would like to just spend a lot
of time with all of them mostly Celine
Dion yeah I think sleeping dragon blast
Celine Dion is seems like seems great I
think what accent is great and and she
could just she just sounds like a
nightingale you know fair and I love
music so I think Celine Dion I would
like to just spend most time with of
those three yeah Wesley Inigo Montoya
and Fezzik
how do you kill everybody I find out if
I do it's up its up Wesley and Nico
Montoya I mean well I don't wanna I
wouldn't marry an eagle Montoya just
because he feels like a real you know it
would be in and out he's a real love and
believes I would want to open my heart
to him in any way because he just feels
like he's comfortable
Wesley which Wesley the sweet farm boy I
mean all day long but this guy who has
now become the new Dread Pirate Roberts
yeah he's gonna be out marauding well
I'm home with the kids no thank you
and then Fezzik he did and along that
exactly so anyway I I just feel like all
three of them have incredible drawbacks
both for a long term and fly-by-night
relationships very fair and one last one
for you Ryan Reynolds as Deadpool Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool in Wolverine
Origins or Ryan Reynolds as Green
Lantern just kill all of them very fit
yeah I feel like Ryan Reynolds Ryan
Reynolds off the map I would just put R
I would just kill I mean honestly with
all respect to Blake and the kids cuz
she seems lovely and those those those
girls are great but I think that I just
I just feel like Ryan Rhett it's enough
already
honestly enough he's everywhere enough I
just saw billboard outside it was just
Ryan Reynolds it was just and it wasn't
even a movie it was actually I'm saying
like house there's an advertisement for
Ryan Reynolds existence yeah Ryan
Reynolds the man it's enough enough with
it and then one last question for you is
there anything that we do not see in
this film that that was left out because
it was in fact r-rated in the stuff that
we did yes well I mean there was it he
tried to you know make it a little more
r-rated than that I would allow but I
fought him off so no I think everything
and everything we shot is there we shot
very very quickly sirens were getting
near very very clowder as the day went
on so you know they did it fast so I
think they used most of most of most
everything we shot we didn't we didn't
let it get to r-rated
because that was the point Ryan's like
oh I want kids who love me too now so he
wanted to be like kid-friendly and you
said you fought him off so what you're
saying is that you're stronger than Ryan
Reynolds yes I mean I don't look it I
get it
my son wanted to go as Deadpool for
Halloween and he wanted me to go as
Deadpool with him hmm and so I put on I
got a dead foot and my kid my kid said
oh you don't look the same it's a little
different I think you don't look the
same I said I'm still strong so I but I
did fight him off
yeah we look different naturally I mean
uh I mean he throws out that suit like a
damn champion bigger scrappy like but
I'm scrappy because I'm scrappy and I
don't play by the minute
you